hi hello my name is Casio is and today I
talking about nonlinear parametric
models of vastic fluid flows this is a
joint work with Alan Captain Nathan
goods and Stevie
Bruton
okay first let's talking about reduceed
order model in fluid mechanics we have
like this big picture you select your
flu canonical or a benchmark flu or
Benchmark geometry and then after your
simulation you capture a snapshot using
a dimensionality reduction you can
analyze some information in terms of
your Dynamic for example you can obtain
a simple representation of your Dynamic
using the temporal coefficient this is
classical pod Galler in
projection
okay more recently we
have incorporate machine learn and deep
learn learning strategy to create to
construct more sophisticated reduced
order model in this case datadriven
reduced order models are widely applied
in neonian fluing
mechanics in our work we are interest to
extend this idea for nonon and flu
mechanics basically we select one type
of nutonian materials the Visas fluid
with we applied a sparse identification
of nonlinear Dynamics the CD algorithm
to construct a data deriven model a
sparse data deriven model where we can
include an information about the
parameter then this is a fully
parametric nonlinear
model but what are nonon and fluids we
have some information using this plots
but basically many materials behave as a
nonon like for example real materials as
for instance the blood some foods oil
and pant and when you look for the plots
in this in this slide you can observe
for nonon and materials a nonlinear
relation between for example the
viscosity and the strain
rate therefore it's
important to simulate this class of flow
and compare with Newtonian one for
example this is a very very
classical Benchmark or set up this is
Rod climb effect we have on the left the
Newtonian fluid and the right we have
the VIS Galas one you can observe for
Newtonian the fluid is dipping while for
non neonian the fluid is climbing the
rod therefore simulations of complex
materials like for example bis elastic
flows
the simulations are very expensive and
then it's important to think or to
construct reduce order model in order to
have more information about the Dynamics
in this complex
situation okay we start our work using a
very simple geometry a square okay just
as a illustration we have some
simulations and I includ in the plots
for example we have the first column a
low values for venberg number in other
words we have the flows Where You
observe a luminar behavior or just a
steady Behavior if you capture the
information of the stress Tor in the
center of the
domain but in the middle you can if you
include more elasticity in the system
you can observe a transition from the
luminar to one oscillatory regime and if
you continue increasing the elasticity
in the flow you can see a transition
from this oscillatory regime to a chotic
one if you construct a map varying the
parameters in our simulation using this
geometry the four row me Benchmark you
have two parameters because we are using
a simplified V Scholastic model the O
Droid B if you analyze these parameters
if you change followes of these
parameters the fenberg number and
beta you can analyze transitions from
steady to oscillatory and chaotic
therefore this geometry is very simple
but you can analyze some transitions
some bations and also the presence of
the laska turbulence just using this
geometer full order model we have some
equations Where We Are interest to to
simulate to capture the snapshots we
have the mass and the momentum equation
it's important that we are highlighting
the nonon contribution on the the moment
of equation we are using the old Droid
be fluid as I said and then we have one
constitutive equation for the
confirmation tensor the tensor denoted
as letter
C you can apply the decomposition and
obtain information on the is Matrix B
There is a square that is a square root
matrix it's important to mention that c
is a symmetric positive definite Matrix
and then you can apply this
decomposition in terms of
non-dimensional parameters we have the
rown number in the equation we have the
vienberg as I said is related to the
elasticity and you have beta beta is the
rtio between the viscosities on the
system the the solvent viscos and and
the polymeric disc CA but in this work
we just analyze one parameter in our
reduced order model we we fix at beta
and we investigate the influence of the
vienberg number it's important because
the vienberg number is related between
the
competition uh between elas and viso
first
okay first step in our algorithm is to
produce information about the tensor B
and then we apply the proper orthogonal
de composition and you capture snapshots
at the time okay we are just using the
the the tensor b h because we are
considering low Ral number flows and
then the Velocity in this case is not
considering to extract the
data if you look for the Pod modes the
spatial modes and the tempor
coefficients you can see some variation
in the space for the first to the second
and the third mode and also this
oscillatory behavior for the temporal
coefficients
okay more information about the par the
pair trajectories we have the first five
temporal coefficients in the simulation
just to confirm that we are for now we
are considering just one oscillatory
regime our algorithm is based in the
CD you know cind is a datadriven
framework and can help you to produce
spars reduce order model more details
about C the framework you can check the
videos of the Stevie bruten channel in
our work we have extend the idea of the
indd because now we are considering some
information about the parameters for
example we extend the dictionary the
library we are using now the temporal
coefficients and also one part to
represent the parameter of the flow
where now we are using the visar number
it's important to talk now in this
moment that we are just using the first
two temporal coefficients to produce our
reduce or model using the VIS elastic
data okay this is the
main part of this conversation because
now this is the dynamical system that we
can produce using the Syd algorithm
observe we have one part related to the
linear part and we have one additional
part this is letter T is related to the
cubic terms okay but we can appli these
terms for a fixed parameter or if you
are using a par periz system observe we
have a more
complex complex term but now we have now
we have the parameter inside the
system okay uh I don't have time to talk
on about stability details but you can
check in our prep print sem analysis
about that our model is stable it is
very important to simulate using a
reduced order model also you can check
some structure in terms of the
coefficients on that Matrix therefore we
are including some interpretation of the
system looking for these coefficients
for the fixed parameter or if you are
using a parameterized system finally we
use the first two modes to construct
relation for the third and the fourth
modes using this sparse algebraic Rel
relationship all details you can check
in our prep print let's talk about
results now we are plotting the
trajectories for the first modes and you
can see a very good agreement between
data and our response of the reduced
order model in addition we plot the
energy on the system the energy on the
temporal coefficients the letter K where
k the lipn function as a function of the
time and you can looking for this
picture just to confirm the system is
stable when you're just including the F
the the first modes in our
analysis okay it's important talking
about
reconstruction if you look now I am just
considering one one component of of B
Matrix the the square root t for this
component you you can see that we have
low error in terms of reconstruction
observe that the maximum error in this
case is just is is less is lower than 2%
and then this is another important point
in terms of our reduce order model if
you look for the Reconstruction as a
function of the time for example in this
case we are plot the trace of the
confirmation tensor you have the SD or
response of a reduced order model and
the data you can see a good agreement in
other words we can capture the main
signatures of the flow using a very
reduce order model like a sparse reduce
order model and then we can gain in CPU
time because to solve a reduce order
model is is is is very simple compared
with a full simulation in this
case finally we analyze our results for
a parametric model okay we have two
vales for training training data where
these vales for theising BG numbers are
related to a oscillatory regime if you
look for the interpolation highlighted
in
yellow in this slide you can see that
okay you can capture results using the
interpolation data but also it's
important to mention if you use a more
if you increase a device embar number a
high voles for example for device embar
number you can use this to train after
the training just to testing for
extrapolation value of device and number
this is highlight and and purple in your
in in your screen and then you can see
increasing the elasticity you can apply
the reduce order model and you capture
in good agreement when you compare the
data and the response of the C
model we also applied for a more for a
high higher vienberg number it's a very
complicated Benchmark when you increase
the vienberg number because you have
more
chaotic Behavior or a periodic and our
system can capture our our dynamical
system can capture the temporal Behavior
also if you look for the energy on the
system the energy is is keep it like
okay you have a stable the stable
strategy okay okay now some conclusions
of this work first it's important
because we have applied for a simple
geometry for just one vaski model first
steps to construct a data driven reduced
order model but it's important to
mention that we have used a
parameterized strategy in other words
now our model is able to capture the
variation of the parameter in addition
we can according to our result result
the prediction the time prediction then
prediction in terms of Dynamics the
predictions are are good agreement with
the data and also we observe that good
quality in the Reconstruction of the
flow we have some limitations and then
in some motivation for next steps first
we needed to improve our strage when we
are going to a elastic turbulence or
more chaotic dynamic
also we needed to incorporate more
complex nonon models or non neonian
equations and finally it would be very
important to investigate new geometers
or new benchmarks in non newon and fluid
mechanics I would like to thanks our
sponsor and your patient thank you